really striking all right republican
congressman mike gallagher of wisconsin
condemned the president and his
supporters before and
after yesterday's riot at capitol hill
he joins us now congressman good morning
thank you so much for being with us good
morning
what was your experience like yesterday
on the floor when all of this broke out
well it all uh spiraled out of control
very quickly
i was in my office and you started
hearing flashbangs in the distance which
was presumably
the capitol police trying to get the
rioters to step back and the rioters
violently confronted them and somehow
breached the security perimeter of the
capitol
and all of a sudden were running around
statuary hall
the vice president was rushed off the
floor of the house of representatives by
secret service and
these images started to emerge as the
the you know
the flashbangs continued of the house
floor being barricaded windows broken i
mean the whole thing
was absolute chaos it was not something
i thought i would ever see
in the united states capital so it was a
very dark day it was very concerning day
i was very concerned for
a lot of my colleagues and i found
myself barricaded in my own office
with a couple of my staff members
thinking about you know how do we if the
worst comes to worst how do we
how do we keep this office safe how do i
keep my staff safe and it was just
you know it was a very very dark day did
you feel like your life was
in danger at some point no i never felt
that
i mean i but i was you know i was
thinking that the closest
thing this resembled was some things i
saw in iraq when i
served in uniform over a decade ago i
mean it was just that
chaotic but i never really felt that my
life was in danger but when the images
started to emerge i thought that some of
my colleagues who were on the house
floor at the time
their life could be in danger and then
ultimately tragically
um a woman was shot and she lost her
life and my understanding is the death
toll is that
four now so it's absolutely tragic and i
think we have to confront head on the
fact that there
was a real danger to giving
millions of americans false hope that
somehow
congress was going to overturn the
results
of the election on january 6. i mean my
view is that congress that is not our
role constitutionally it's for the
states and the people
to resolve their own elections january 6
has always been merely a ministerial
meeting
of congress not a meaningful forum for
litigating or relitigating an election
and i think what the objectors
misunderstood is that somehow by just
having a debate for two hours
the protesters were going to be
satisfied
well clearly that was not the case and
we incited some very extreme passions
and that
resulted in destruction and even death
extreme passions indeed congressman
gallagher and let's talk about that for
a second because considering what
everybody had gone through that day
and how traumatic and upsetting it was
that several of your republican
colleagues
still continue to voice their objections
what did you think about that
well i thought clearly after what we
watched happen for hours
of utter destruction that we would
reconvene
and the objectors would drop their
objections
yes a lot of people they went right back
to
the debate they went right back to the
reckless
suggestion that congress had a role in
overturning the election on january 6th
so
i was quite frankly astounded at that uh
i was astounded that there wasn't a
movement from the top down to prevent
that from happening i guess
i was gratified that the number of
senators who were going to object
was reduced to a very small number and
perhaps we objected to a fewer number of
states than we originally were but
i i just don't understand how after
witnessing what we witnessed
and knowing knowing that
congressman mike gallagher thank you so
much for being with you with us this
morning we're glad you're okay we're
glad everyone's okay
i'm glad the country's okay